Hey guys, welcome back to the dome today, we're gonna be trying out something that a ton of people have requested
We're gonna try pouring molten salt into both water and ice
I'm pretty sure both of these are experiments that have previously done by The Backyard Scientist and he had some really cool results
He's got some great stuff on this channel
Go check it out if you want to see more, but we didn't think it was fair that he had all of the fun
So we want to try it out ourselves
Plus we got these nifty clear blocks of ice that you can really see through pretty well and I want to see how that looks
On camera. A quick run-through of how our salt pouring device works. It's a very basic frame with just this one piece
It's on a hinge
it's got a steel cup that our crucible fits nicely down into the first binder clip will hold the steel cup in place on the
Hinge portion and then I have additional binder clips which can fit on the steel cup and that can prevent our crucible from tipping out
There's a string attached to the back of the hinged portion and when that gets pulled the whole thing tips
Three two one
That was pretty cool the water definitely looked like he was exploding it didn't break the tank which I kind of thought it might
And I'm not sure what makes the difference between breaking the tank and not breaking the tank. Maybe I need more salt
Maybe they need hotter salt a lot of variables in there, but that reacted very violently and very quickly
It's slightly warm water
Not really hot water. I think we need to try that again
Three-two-one
I Honestly think this is just stronger glass than the aquarium glass well the heat from our crucible
Is now starting to burn our wood. So let's take that off
Nice
We got another pretty good explosion that water really had a lot of energy coming out of it it was flying through the air
I'm a little surprised our glass didn't break, but this glass is actually really strong stuff
Remember, this is the same thing that we use as our vacuum chamber
It can hold a surprising amount the pressure apparently both pushing from the outside and from the inside
So I don't think there's any cracks or breaks on this
So it really did a good job of containing all of our water and while it may have been exciting to watch it explode
It's good to know how strong these things are
Really our binder clips are quite warm
Yeah, we did manage to catch fire to the hinged portion of our little device here that was fun not unsurprising though overall though
I think this pouring device works pretty nicely
Now we've tried a couple times pouring it into water
I want to see what happens if we pour our molten salt into a block of ice
Here, we've got a block of ice probably weighs about 20 pounds and this is ice that's designed for ice carving
Which means it is super clear. You can see through this ice pretty darn
Well, I've drilled a hole about halfway down through the block of ice which you can see through the side
We're gonna try pouring some salt down into that hole and see what happens
You do a test
I'm gonna fill this with water and see where it pours so I can have the block lined up in just the right spot
It was still warm
There's some pours
That's where it lands first
It's probably a pretty good spot
All right. Let's get some salt melting put it into our pouring device and pour it into a block of ice
That sound three two one
Missed I think
oh I think it still is cracking the surface of the block. I just saw their tiny little cracks appearing in it and then they
Seal up right away. Oh
It looks like a lot of our salt
Landed on the back of the block and didn't really get down into the drilled out hole of it
So we'll try scooting the block back and doing this again
three two one
Ha ha ha Wow, all right. Well it didn't blow up the block of ice but that was
Amazingly loud. That was pretty much an explosion right there. Holy cow
We have sort of an echo chamber in the dome behind us. But that was really loud. It sounded like a gunshot
surprised We didn't crack the block quite surprised
Take this thing off before it lights my whole contraption on fire
This will be unwise but I'm just gonna pour the rest rest of this little salt right on there
Wow is so loud
That's nuts the blocks of icing you can usually buy at the grocery store or something like that are just chipped ice that have been compressed
Down into a block and they're not nearly as strong as a solid clear block of ice
Although I bet we could get one of those to blow up if we had a slightly different layout
Perhaps if we had a taller block with a longer hole drilled down into it
We would be able to get more salt down inside the ice and instead of shooting up into the air like we had here
More of it would push outward that might be something that we try in the future
I do happen to have one of these blocks of compressed ice. Let's see what happens when we pour a little salt into here
Three two one
Exploded pretty well
exactly as far as I had drilled the hole I
Had really only drilled to about that far in because I have a short drill bit
That's how deep it exploded. And then after it exploded salt tunnel the way down in
That was pretty explosive
Guys we've tried a couple different things with molten salt and ice and I haven't seen the result
I was most hoping for which is to see the block of ice crack open or even possibly explode
So I've got another block of clear ice. It's actually an entirely different day
I came back up here with the new block of ice
I've got more salt melting in the foundry and we're gonna try this one more time
in addition to being a new block of ice
This one is actually also a little bit thicker and I've drilled the hole a little bit deeper down into it
So hopefully there will be more molten salt down inside the ice
Transferring heat around at the same time
three two one
Woah
it exploded
Great
Yeah
Whoo. Oh, that was beautiful
Beautiful. Look at that. That is a clean
Crack ting like you didn't fragment everywhere. Basically just tore the block in half
That is interesting. So I guess not terribly surprisingly it tries to take the path of least resistance
This block was thicker left to right than it was front to back and it cracked along the thinner axis
That is the result that I was hoping for
So a larger block of ice with a hole drilled farther down into it gave us a much more explosive result
Yeah, you can see how it went all back together that
Was beautiful
Hey guys. Thanks for watching
If you're not a subscriber
Yet hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video or you want to watch it again
Click up here at the top click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks you should watch next
That's it for now. Have fun. Be safe. See you tomorrow